اهلا بكم من جديد في جديد قضيه الوثائق
السريه طلب فريق الدفاع عن الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب من القاضي
المشرف على قضيه الوثائق في فلوريدا تاجيل
المحاكمه لاسباب من بينها ان فريق دفاع
ترامب اعتبر ان القضيه تواجه تحديات
قانونيه وسياسيه ويجب تاجيلها لما بعد
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لضمان لجنه محلفين
نزيهه تفصل في قضيه الوثائق السريه ممثلون
الادعاء كانوا قد طلبوا من القاضيه الى ان
كان تاجيل النظر في القضيه الى الحادي عشر
من ديسمبر بدلا من الرابع عشر من اغسطس
لاعطاء الادعاء والدفاع لاعطاء الادعاء
ودفاع اذا مزيدا من الوقت لكن يبدو ان
محامي ترامب كان لهم راي اخر فطلبوا مزيدا
من الوقت ووصف الجدول الزمني الذي طلبته
الحكومه بانه امر غير واقعي محمد ترامبا
طلبه ايضا من المحكمه سحب الامر الحالي
الذي يحدد وقت المحاكمه وتاجيل اي دراسه
لموعد جديد بشانها معلنين بل معلنين الامر
بانه غير في ضوء متطلبات حمله الانتخابيه
والادله الكثيره التي تحتاج مراجعه دقيقه
بالاضافه الى قضايا اخرى في المقابل لم
ترد وزاره العدل الامريكيه على طلب تاجيل
المحكمه او سحب الامر الحالي حول عقدها
الشهر المقبل وتفيد مصادر في العدل
الامريكيه بان قضيه الوثائق السريه ستجري
وفق مجموعه صارمه من القواعد المنصوص
عليها في قانون اجراءات المعلومات السريه
والذي يهدف الى حمايه الادله السريه والى
تقنين الكشف عنها فهل سينجح ترامب في
تخطيها كما فعل في عشرات القضايا السابقه
وقضيه الوثائق 37 تهمه تتعلق باحتفاضه
بوثائق سريه
عرقله عمل المحققين الذين كانوا يسعون
لاستعاده الوثائق
في يونيو مثل ترامب امام محكمه في ميامي
وابعدت عنه التهم الموجهه اليه
الموعد المبدئي المقرر للمحكمه في الرابع
عشر من اغسطس
ممثلون الادعاء طلبوا من القاضيه الم كان
تاجيل النظر في القضيه الى الحادي عشر من
ديسمبر
محامو الدفاع عدم وجود سبب لاي محكمه
عاجله وافضل طريقه لتحقيق العداله هي
الاستمرار
معنى من اورلاندو كم حرب مدير التحالف
الامريكيه للشرق الاوسط اهلا بك من واشنطن
دكتور ادمغه الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه
اهلا بك كذلك هل باعتقادك يعني تقبل
المحكمه بان تؤجل الجلسات الى ما بعد
الانتخابات او الى ديسمبر على الاقل او
ستصر على اب او اغسطس اولا مرحبا
والمشاهدين الكرام يعني اذا المحكمه ستنظر
ما هو الشعب الامريكي بشكل عام طبعا الراي
العار الامريكاني هو لتاخير هذه
الدعاوى والمحاكم حتى بعد الانتخابات بال
2024 لانه شعبيه الرئيس ترامبليون بالحزب
الجمهوري هي بحوالي الخمسين بالميه وما
اكثر والراي العام الامريكي يعتبر بان هذه
المحكمه من قبل الحزب الديمقراطي واداره
الرئيس بايدن بالذات ما الا هي انتهاك
سياسي
اكثر شيء منافسه وخاصه بانه الرئيس بايدن
عندما كان
بمجلس الشيوخ وعندما كان نائبا للرئيس كان
لديه وثائق سريه واكتشف عنها مؤخرا وكانت
بالالوف هذا الوثائق السريه وحتى اليوم لم
يكن اي محاكم باتجاه الرئيس
بمجرد التاجيل ايضا مش تسييس يعني لماذا
نقبل بفكره التاسيس الان واذا اجلت لا يعد
تسييسا يعني فقط لانه لصالح
وماذا لو فازت الرئاسه يعني هل ستصبح لجنه
المحلفين نزيهه
لا لانه اذا انزلت اليوم اذا استمرت هذه
المحاكم ستاخذ اشهر واشهر وستكون ضمن
الحمله الانتخابيه مما تؤثر على الراي
العام
الامريكي ويقولون ربما سيحاكم فلماذا
سنصوت له واذا تاخرت لما بعد الانتخابات
الامريكيه عندئذ اذا كان هو رئيس في ذلك
الوقت فيسقطها واذ لم يكن رئيسا ربما
المحكمه المحاكم الامريكيه ستسقطها لان ما
بقى يؤثر الرئيس الامريكيه ما بقى ياسر
الرئيس ترامب على القوى السياسيه في
الولايات المتحده الدكتور ما رايك
تحياتي لك وللاستاذ تام من الواضح لان
هناك عده مسائل تتعلق بهذه المحاكمه طبعا
الادعاء ووزاره العدل تريد ان تكون تبدا
هذه المحاكمه بسرعه ولذلك طلبوا في ان
يكون ذلك في شهر ديسمبر القادم بينما
محمود رامبل كان لهم وجهه نظر مختلفه واين
هو الخلافه الخلاف طبعا بالنسبه للادعاء
العام يقول بان المحاكمه يجب ان تكون
سريعه وبالتالي وان لا تؤجل لاسباب لاغراض
سياسيه كما تفضلت حضرتك وذكرت ولكن بدعوه
المحامون عن الرئيس ترامب لديهم وجهه نظر
اخرى وفيها ايضا بعض
الشرعيه الى حد اولا ان هناك عدد كبير من
الوثائق والوثائق السريه هناك حوالي
833 الف صفحه من المواد التي يجب دراستها
والنظر هناك حوالي
122,650 رساله بريد الكتروني
و300
وثيقه اخرى ومن بينها هناك ايضا
الاجهزه المراقبه التي كانت تراقب ما يجري
خاصه فيما يتعلق
هذه الوثائق في مارالاجو ايضا يجب ولنعلم
عددها ولكن هناك اشهر من اجهزه المراقبه
التي تابعت هذه القضيه اذا هناك هذه تحتاج
الى وقتها لان هناك مشكله عمليه
عملياتيه او عمليه بحيث انه يجب على الاقل
ان يكون للدفاع الحق في مراقبه ومتابعه
وقراءه هذه الوثائق النقطه الثانيه هي
النقطه السياسيه هي وهذه مره اشار اليها
مقام ترامب وهو ان هذه قد تكون محاكمه
سياسيه لان هناك شخص خصم مرشح خاصم للرئيس
الذي
سيكون هو ايضا مرشح للرئاسه وبالتالي
وتقوم بالمحاكمه وتوجيه الاتهامات وزاره
عدل
الرئاسه الرئيس بايدن وهذا هو البعد الاخر
لماذا لا يكون التوازن لماذا لا يكون
احداث توازن بفتح ملف الوثائق السريه
الاخرى المتعلقه ببايدن او بهلر كلينتون
او باي مسؤول ظهرت عنه وثائق محسوب على
الديمقراطيين
الفرق بين كما يقول على الاقل المدعون
العامون وان اداره بايدن او الرئيس بايدن
عندما علموا بهذا الموضوع تعاونوا مع
الاجهزه الامنيه وسلموا الوثائق طبعا بعض
هذه الوثائق اولا هذه الوثائق
تم اكتشافها قبل انتخابات الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الماضيه
والانتخابات عفوا النصفيه في
ولذلك فان الاداره الامريكيه كان عليها ان
تطلع الراي العام ولم يطلع الراي العام
على ما حدث الا بعد اشهر من انتخاب الرئيس
بايدن هل الحجه قائمه ووازنه ايضا في
القضايا المتعلقه بهنتر بايدن
قضيه هنتر بايدن اعتقد ان لها ابعاد
مختلفه لان قضيه هنتر بايدن هي قضيه الى
حد كبير تتعلق بابن الرئيس وليس بالرئيس
وان كان هناك ابعاد سياسيه ترابط بين
الاثنين ولكن طبيعه القضايا مختلفه
استاذ توم حرب هل تعتقد ان التسييس في هذا
الموضوع هو الضغط في قضيه ترامب او الضغط
ايضا في الملفات الاخرى متعلقه بوثائق
بايدن السريه وقضايا نجله
هنالك تواضع من قبل وزاره العدل الامريكيه
وحتى المخابرات الامريكيه ان كانت الاف بي
اي والسي اي تواطئت مع اداره بايدن
وتتواصل اليوم حتى ضد الرئيس السابق ترامب
فمن هذه الناحيه يعتبر الشعب الامريكي انه
اليوم نحن رايحين على طريق انزلاق اذا
بدانا بكل فتره انتخابات نواجه اتهامات
للمنافسه وتكون وزاره العدل بدعه يعني نحن
صفينا مثل بلدان جمهوريات الماج وهذا لا
يجب ان يحصل في الولايات المتحده فمن هذه
النقطه بالذات يجب ان تؤجل هذه المحاكم
لما بعد الانتخابات الامريكيه لانه ولكن
لماذا يتم النظر الى الموضوع ايضا من قبل
هذا الشعب اللي عم تحكي عنه المؤيد جزء
منه المؤيد لترامب على انه في شخص حاول
متهم بتحدي القانون وبتجاوزه وبالتالي هو
مطالب بالخضوع مثل اي مواطن اخر امريكي له
هذا سؤال كثير مهم ولكن نحن عرفنا انه من
سنه 2016
والمحاكم والتواطئ من قبل الحزب
الديمقراطي
والمخابرات الامريكيه في ذلك الوقت يعني
قالوا انه في تواطئ بين اداره المرشح لذلك
الوقت ترامب ومع الروس وطلع بعد ثلاث
سنوات تقل كبير على الشعب الامريكاني في
عز زهوه الرئيس ترامب وطلعت بالنتيجه انه
هي ابداع كان وفبركه من الحزب الديمقراطي
فلذلك الامر اليوم الشعب الامريكي لا يصدق
هذه الاجهزه وعلى هذه الاجهزه ان تنظف
واعاده صياغتها واصلاحات ضمن هذه الاجهزه
حتى المواطن الامريكان يصفي عنده ثقه ان
كان بالمخابرات الامريكانيه لما قالوا
مثلا جهاز الكمبيوتر للسيد هانتر بايدن هو
ابداع روسي من قبل 51 شخصيه كانوا
بالمخابرات الامريكيه يعني نحن كمواطنين
صدقنا هذا الموقف من 51 شخصيه ليتبين بعد
ذلك انه هذا غير صحيح يعني اين ثقه الشعب
مع وزاره العدل الامريكيه واين الثقه
الشعب مع الجنس المخابرات الامريكي دكتور
المؤسساتيه اعمق من خلاف حزبين او شخصين
فعلا هناك مشكله
مؤسساتيه بدانا ان نشعلها منذ التسعينات
من القرن الماضي وذلك عندما راينا هناك
غياب الثقه في المؤسسه الامريكيه وخاصه في
النخب الحاكمه في واشنطن ولذلك راينا في
ذلك الوقت بروز روسبيرو هو شخصيه يعني
كانت معروفه جيدا باليونير الى حد ما رجل
اعمال ولكنه كان مستقلا ودخل الانتخابات
وحصل على 29 او 30% من استطلاعات الراي
ولكنه حتى في حرم من المشاركه في
الانتخابات كذلك كان هناك رالف نادر وهو
مرشح يمثل تقريبا
التيار التيارات التقدميه في الولايات
المتحده ومدافع عن حقوق المستهلكين وايضا
ابعدوا هؤلاء
ووضعت عقبات امامهم وحتى ايضا امام
باتريكانين وهو مرشح جمهوري محافظ في ذلك
الوقت من ابرز مساعدي الرئيس ريجن ولذلك
اعتقد ان هناك فعلا هذه المشكله الاساسيه
وهي اننا بدانا نرى مشكله ثقه لدى العديد
من الامريكيين بان واشنطن والنخب التي
تحكم في الولايات المتحده لم تعد تمثلهم
لا تمثل القوه السياسيه وكبار الشركات
كبريات الشركات والمركب العسكري التقني
الصناعي الاعلام قراءه وفيه شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور غريب
استاذ طعام حرب مدير التحالف الامريكي شرق
قسطنطين شكرا جزيلا لك كذلك تحياتي اليكما
[موسيقى]
بقونا معكم لنتابع ايضا في بانوراما بعد
قليل نحو الكناري بوصله هجره غير مشروعه
بديله مليئه بقصص الموت تغير جغرافيه
قوارب الهجره من المتوسط الى الاطلسي لضعف
الرقابه ام لتزايد نشاط شبكات التهريب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات